hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll we have yet another experimental
kind of podcast today our guest is Kate
Jeffery who is literally an
experimentalist an experimental
neuroscientist at University College
London where she studies the cognitive
map within the brain how we find where
we are in the universe and how that
triggers certain neurons in our brains
but we're not going to be talking about
neuroscience for the most part Kate and
I were both participants in a workshop
in Costa Rica a Kavli workshop on space
time and the brain on this general idea
of relating space and time to have there
represented in brains I gave a talk
while I was there on complexity and its
relationship to entropy and Kate hearing
the talk responded to it in her own talk
talking about the evolution of
complexity in a biological and
environmental context where things are
much more subtle and nuanced in a lot of
details that as a physicist I could
gloss over so together we thought that
it'd be fun rather than just me
interviewing her about her stuff to talk
about this area of the relationship
between entropy and complexity how
complex structures come to be over time
whether it's cosmologically here on
earth or with even within a social
domain and then how complexity goes away
there can be catastrophes right there
are extinction events there's the
ultimate equilibration of the universe
so this is more than any other podcast
I've ever had I think I am doing just as
much of the talking as my official guest
it's possible that I'm doing more of the
talking than Kate did but anyway we're
both sort of trying to learn things this
is neither one of us laying down the law
from on high it's a true
interdisciplinary exploration and I
think you're gonna find it's a lot of
fun so let's go
[Music]
Kait Jeffrey welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so this is an unusual
but fun episode I think in the sense
that we're gonna try to make it a
two-way conversation right you know some
people some podcasters just make every
one of their conversations a two-way
conversation I do try to let the guests
do most of the talking but we're gonna
be a little bit more balanced here to
maybe explain why that's the case why
don't you give us you know some of your
background where what you do for a
living in your respectable part of your
day job so I'm not a physicist at all so
I have to start with an immediate
disclaimer here I'm a neuroscientist and
I'm interested in how the brain makes a
internal representation of the world
so how creates knowledge structures and
I do that by implanting electrodes into
the brains of rats and mice and
listening to the signals and then trying
to correlate what we can pick up with
what the animal that with its you know
is sensory inputs its behavior and we're
really trying to understand how it
comprehends space and forms memories of
its experiences and all of that kind of
thing so that sort of led me to thinking
about space and time and what that
actually means and thinking of some
bigger questions and that's how I kind
of started straying into your domain to
some extent right well we were at a
conference together a coffee workshop in
Costa Rica on space time in the brain so
those are three big topics obviously and
I gave a talk where I gave part of my
usual spiel about entropy and complexity
and I can rehearse that here but then
you gave a talk that sort of built on
that in some way were you already
thinking along these lines you must have
been you seem pretty prepared yes so I
had come along to that meeting prepared
to talk about how the brain makes a map
of three-dimensional space but my talk
was on the last day and by the time we
had got to that point and the physicists
and the neuroscientists had exchanged a
few conversations I felt that I had less
to contribute that was going to be
useful about my research and
or to contribute about some other things
that I've been thinking a lot about and
so I had never actually formalized those
things before so I had to kind of sit
down and construct from scratch of an
assemblage of my ideas but but what I
had been thinking about for the last few
months is how the nervous system has
really come to be in the course of the
evolution of the universe and the
evolution of life and how its managed to
navigate the various bumps in the road
along the way so there have been a
number of major extinctions for example
in the evolution of life and of course
we're facing another one at the moment
which has been occupying my thoughts a
lot and so I just been thinking about
the fact that life seems to be
inherently unstable and yet we've seen
more and more of it accumulate as the
universe has gone on and I just got
curious about the dynamics of them why
does that happen
so it was fantastic to be able to talk
to you physics guys that we want
thermodynamic kind of understanding and
when you talked about complexity and
entropy and all of that I just had so
many questions so I thought well I'm
gonna lay out some of my questions and
then we can talk yeah and here we are
sort of the culmination of that cool so
how should we do this you want me to
start with my like I said my
conventional spiel about entropy and
complexity and then we can build on that
because that you know I think that
you've your take on it is in in many
ways a lot more nuanced like I'm just
doing the simplest physics thing where
we try to get everything it's a
spherical cow and everything is very
simple and there's someone who cares
about life and biospheres and things
like that you're you are very correctly
saying it's a bit more complicated than
that when we get to the real world yeah
so yeah I think you should start
definitely okay so this is something
where I became interested in it because
I became interested in entropy
you know entropy for those out there who
somehow have escaped me talking about
this is a way of talking about how
disorderly or how disorganized things
are and more particularly if you have a
set of tiny little constituents atoms or
molecules or cells or whatever and there
are different ways to arrange them
macroscopically and you can see
certain features of those macroscopic
arrangements so like you look at my
favorite example is a cup of coffee with
cream being mixed into it you see where
the cream is you see where the coffee is
but you don't see where the individual
molecules are right so look big
Boltzmann in the 1870s said entropy is
basically a way of counting how many
ways there are to arrange the
microscopic microscopic constituents to
give you that macroscopic look so in
other words we coarse-grain the
description in terms of what we can see
about it microscopically and we just
count the number of microscopic states
that would contribute to that way of
being and there's a rule the second law
of thermodynamics it says that typically
the entropy increases because very
naturally if you start in a
configuration where there's only a small
number of arrangements that look that
way just by natural evolution without
any direction you will move toward a
situation where you're in a higher
entropy state because there are more
ways to be high entropy than to be low
entropy that's a very quick second law
of thermodynamics in trouble but that
makes sense right yeah do you use the
second law of thermodynamics a lot as a
working psychologist biologists
um not me personally more theoretical
neuroscientists think about it in terms
of free energy and oh yes theory and
that type of thing I just tend to
encounter it when I mess things up in an
experiment entropy is part of our daily
lives that's certainly true but but so
can I just ask you a bit more about this
notion because yeah I understand how it
works for a box of gas molecules let's
say but I start to run into difficulties
of understanding when I think about for
example the entropy in a molecule of DNA
right so it depends it seems to me that
the number of microscopic states that
correspond to that macroscopic state
there's more than there's more than one
set of numbers if you like so one of
them is the number of microscopic States
that would just lead you to a coiled
molecule hmm and one of them is the
number of microscopic states that would
lead you to the the genome for a
a bacterium let's say so microscopically
they look exactly the same it's it's a
viral molecule but the functioning of
that molecule in the bigger picture is
completely different so I struggle with
saying that the entropy of those two
molecules is the same but my
understanding is that a physicist would
say well it is well I think that a
careful physicist would say it depends
in the sense that you know this is this
is if you put your finger on one of the
long-standing controversial aspects
about the bolts money and statistical
mechanical way of talking about entropy
which is that it seems to involve some
human choices in the definition of
things right I mean I tried to make it
sound pretty objective by saying the
macroscopic features that you can
observe are how you coarse-grain
microscopic States into macroscopic ones
but someone could say well who is doing
the observing it does a better observer
have see a different entropy than a
worse one to a large extent in practice
that's not a big worry because the laws
of physics make certain features
microscopically observable to us and not
others so when we see the cream in the
coffee for example even if you built a
robot or even if you met an alien or
whatever none of them is gonna be able
to see the individual molecules and
their positions and momenta they're
basically gonna see the same things that
a human being sees so there is something
robust about nature that suggests
certain ways of course greening into
macro States but when you get to the
edge cases where there's not a lot of
moving parts you know we're used to
having Avogadro's number of molecules
and you're used to having a much smaller
number than that so in a DNA molecule
versus some other sort of polymer of
some sort yeah how what exactly you
count as the microscopic constituents
and how you coarse-grain them into macro
States can matter can be different and
it might depend on functionality I think
which is which is what you're getting at
right like two molecules that might look
the same physically from just a sort of
if you're coarse graining is just how
long is it how stretchy is it you know
how bendy is it to molecules might look
the same but if you're asking what is
its function in the cell those same two
molecules might look very different I
think that my answer is you use whatever
one you want just be consistent once you
start using it so I don't think that the
right physics answer is to say no you
have to ignore the detailed differences
between DNA and some other long molecule
I think that just depends on what
context you're working in and and I
think also that's ok I don't think
that's a flaw I just think it's
something to recognize but are you
saying that entropy is a subjective
things and that the it's context
dependent it is subjective in a sense
it's but it's in the following sense
this is the same thing is true I would
say about any emergent phenomenon right
whenever we have a microscopic
description which is highly accurate
perhaps perfectly precise and there's a
macroscopic description in different
terms which is only a good approximation
it's always the case where we don't have
to use that macroscopic approximation
right like if we were Laplace's daemon
if we knew the location of every
molecule of Freeman coffee in the in the
cup and could do the calculations in our
head we wouldn't need to coarse grain at
all but nevertheless there is something
real and useful about the coarse
graining right there's certain ways of
coarse graining that would make no sense
like we coarse-grained the coffee by
saying in every little region of space
we'll count the number of coffee
molecules and cream molecules or
whatever we don't say you know will
average the number of molecules over
here and then number of molecules at a
completely different place for some
arbitrary crazy reason right and the
reason why is because coarse graining in
that way would give a description that
has no simple dynamics right it's not
robust the nice thing about emergence is
you throw away an enormous amount of
information the locations and velocities
of every individual molecule but what
you keep is still somehow representing a
true pattern in the in the dynamics
right yes I kind of get that but I still
there's a fundamental issue so if you
take a stretch of DNA that is meaningful
so its genes for some organism mm-hmm
then as time goes by and mutations occur
and the DNA degrades the molecule will
have the same macroscopic properties but
it will be degraded within the bigger
picture
so in some sense there's the information
content which which I kind of feel is
somehow associated with entropy the
information content has gone down even
though the microscopic qualities at that
moment haven't changed but where the
macroscopic properties have changed is
when you look at what happens to that
molecule in time because after the
mutation it's going to build a very
degraded funny-looking organism instead
of a normal-looking one so I'm
struggling really with this notion of
what is meant by macroscopic properties
are they just slices in the here-and-now
or do you need to consider the entire
history of that system over time as well
as within this space well certainly the
usual way of doing it the history over
time wouldn't matter like that's that's
if it does matter then your physical
description is enormous ly more
complicated it's not that it's
impossible but that we we very much like
in physics to think in Markovian terms
in the Scent Markovian just in the
simple sense that what happens at one
moment depends on what happened in the
immediate previous moment but not the
entire history of the past and likewise
the future is predictable from right now
not from information in the past but
what kind of prediction you're making is
certainly relevant when you decide what
is the information that you use that you
take into account when you make your
macrostates right so if you care about
the function of that molecule within the
cell then I certainly think that there
are features of the cell that would go
into your course the features of the
molecule that would go into your coarse
graining like a slightly degraded DNA
molecule that didn't do its biological
function
it would be completely legit to count as
a different macro state than one that
looked pretty much physically the same
but did its function perfectly well but
then you have taken time into account
because function is nothing that happens
in time well I would say that what I'm
taking into account is counterfactual
statements like would the molecule act
differently even right now if different
things were happening to it I think
that's okay to take into account but I
don't need to actually see into the
future to see what will happen to this
actual example of the molecule but you
wouldn't be able to distinguish it
degraded DNA from a well formed DNA
molecule in that sense until you had
seen what happened to it in the future
or what new you know new the gene
sequence yeah you wouldn't be able to
tell just by looking at it I guess is
what you're saying right or you know in
some fight by using the immediately
macroscopic available information to you
you would not be able to distinguish
between them yeah Andy that has no
meaning until you consider its future
yeah I think that this this is a subtle
edge case where you have there's there's
a whole discussion there are people who
know a lot more about this than I do but
there's a whole discussion about hidden
states within some macro states so
ordinarily in statistical mechanics your
hope is that all the microstates within
Americo State not only look the same but
for the most part they will act the same
now you know that that that's not
exactly true right like within some
macro state of a glass of water there
are some individual microstates where
suddenly it will the water will heat up
accept an ice cube will form in the
water right that's extremely extremely
unlikely and it's a very very tiny
number of macro state of micro States
but they exist and you would never know
just by looking at the glass of water
but we get around that by saying well
they're just so few of those we can
ignore them and again when you get down
to a small number of moving parts you
might not be able to ignore that so I
think that you know a lot of it just
comes down to the fact that you might
not be able to reliably use some of
these statistical mechanical ideas in
regimes where cellular biology or nano
scale physics really matter that seems
like a big statement because the second
law of thermodynamics is that not
supposed to govern the unfolding of the
universe and including living with
things well yes but the universe has a
lot of moving parts in it and it look if
you have three moving parts there's no
such thing as the second law of
thermodynamics right it's just it's just
a waste if you have a hundred then
there's a reasonable approximation to it
and if you have ten to the ten then it's
really really really good so that's we
gotta accept that right I mean
fluctuations and unlikely events are
hugely important at the level of
cellular biology they're completely
irrelevant at the level of what goes on
in your internal combustion engine yeah
so I guess the thing that's been
bothering me about entropy has been this
apparent subjectivity yeah the other
thing I've struggled with is the way in
which it requires space to be meaningful
because all of the descriptions of
entropy that there's sort of
thermodynamic level involved space and
involve things being in one part of the
space or the other is that a fair
statement well it's a fair statement in
physics generally that space is really
important in the sense that space is I'm
thinking I'm talking slowly because as a
physicist I'm trying to answer questions
about like why is there space in the
first place right which you're not
worried about heavily for and we're not
worried about for this conversation but
roughly speaking space is the arena in
which interactions between physical
systems look local right two objects
will interact with each other when they
are at the same or almost the same
location in space in a way that they
won't interact with each other if they
have the same velocity but are in very
different locations in space right so so
space is very very special for exactly
that reason and I think if that should
be true even for biology but you sound
like maybe you're worried about it well
I am a little I don't know if worried is
the right word but in thinking about
entropy at the thermodynamic level it
seems to be to do with probability of
for example particle being in a
particular part of the space that has
gotten woven in with my thinking about
evolution and why evolution has
proceeded the way it has and why life
has slowly increased in complexity the
way it has and it seems to me that space
is a very fundamental part of that
process and what's happening as life
evolves is that life forms that
discovering new ways of extending the
operation of their activities in bigger
spaces or ever bigger times and that
opens up new possibilities for entropy
to flow Halloween is on the way the time
for ghosts and devils and demons and
witches but perhaps scariest of all is
the idea of shopping for life insurance
it can be very intimidating with all the
different choices out there you're not
an expert how many times in your life do
you go around shopping for life
insurance so if you're scared by that
idea try policy genius.com
policy genius is an easy way to shop for
life insurance online it's basically an
educational tool that you can figure out
what all of the different options are
and you can compare quotes from the top
and jurors to get your best price
furthermore when you do apply the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
all the red tape that gets in the way of
making it a straightforward process and
it's not just life insurance policy
genius does car insurance home insurance
and so forth so this October take the
scariness out of buying life insurance
with policy genius go to policy
genius.com get the quotes and you can
apply in minutes or you can just do the
whole thing on the phone right now
policy genius.com yeah no I think that's
exactly right so I mean maybe I can sort
of build on the little spiel I gave
about the second law and and talk about
complexity a little bit because again
I'm thinking about it at the most very
basic physicist level but we want to get
a little bit more nuance during our
conversation here so if you believe that
the history of our universe the last 14
billion years has been a history of
increasing entropy of increasing
disorderliness and randomness then it's
perfectly okay to wonder how complicated
organized
structures like you and me or the
biosphere or whatever came into
existence there's a sort of bad
creationist argument that says it
couldn't have happened because the
biosphere is very organized and the
second law says things just become more
disorganized that's obviously wrong
because the second law only says that
entropy increases in closed systems and
the earth and its biosphere are nowhere
near a closed system we are getting
wonderfully low entropy energy from the
Sun we are increasing the entropy of
that energy and we're sending it back to
the universe with much higher entropy so
the net effect of the earth on the
entropy of the universe is certainly to
increase it in complete accord with the
second law of thermodynamics but it that
just says it's okay it's allowed that
complex structures such as life appeared
on earth that doesn't explain why it
should happen so with Scott Aaronson and
some other folks some students in
postdocs Lauren will left and Brett
Vernis we study this question and we
propose the following thing which
apparently is not completely new but it
well it's a little bit new but it's
related to older ideas as entropy
increases in a closed system if you
think about it carefully
when entropy is really really low things
are organized things are even though you
know that's what it means for entropy to
be low but not only they organize their
simple right there's not that many ways
to be really really low entropy so if
all the cream is on the top of the cup
and all the coffees on the bottom that's
low entropy and simple
whereas when things are high entropy
when all the cream and coffee are mixed
into each other things are simple again
right everything is mixed together
that's very very simple it's in between
that complex structures are allowed to
exist and then you can ask the question
is it actually the case that in the
course of physical evolution complex
structures do come to exist so do the
cream and coffee simply smoothly blend
into each other and everything is simple
all along the way or is it more like
you're stirring with a spoon and you get
some complicated fractal patterns and
and so we did some simple simulations
and we showed that you can get either
one you can get either kind of behavior
and in cases where you wanted to get
complex structures forming that was
allowed as long as there were
correlations in how the cream and coffee
mixed into each other so our hypothesis
is number one that as entropy goes up
complexity starts low grows and then
fades away again and number two there
are situations in which that will happen
in situations at which it won't and at
least one of the ingredients you need
for it to happen are correlations in the
evolutions it can't just be that one
thing interacts with a thing right next
to it there has to be like some rigidity
or some long-range forces that are
pushing things together in concert so
that structure forms on all sorts of
different scales
so the lesson that we take from that
which is not nearly justified by the
work we did but I think is the
extrapolation of it is that the
formation of complex structures like the
biosphere and individual organisms here
on earth is not just despite the fact
that entropy is increasing it's because
of entropy increasingly if it weren't
for entropy increasing we'd be in
equilibrium we have high entropy already
and there would be no living structures
so we our existence as organized low
entropy creatures is actually part of
the general tent general tendency of
things in the universe to increase in
entropy overall but what is driving the
temporal unfolding of the increase in
complexity followed by the decrease in
complexity like what is the thing that's
shaping that evolution of complexity
right well so you know I think again
there's two things there's a simple
thing that it's allowed right like
really it's not allowed to be complex
when entropy is super super low and it's
not allowed to be complex when entropy
is super super high the only place the
complexity could exist is in between and
then the only question is does it as a
matter of fact come into existence and
that's the complicated one so we gave
this really really simple very
you know kind of village idiot to kind
of answer which is that you need some
long-range correlations or long-range
structures
now when you so I think the correct
thing to do like the next step is for me
to hand over to you and say you know in
the real world
how did it happen and what lessons does
that give us for the larger physics
questions of how might it happen in
principle yeah so when I listened to you
talk about this in Costa Rica I had an
aha moment when you talked about these
correlations and space across space and
time because that suddenly seemed to me
to explain why life becomes more complex
because what happens as as life has
evolved is that with each step in
evolution something has happened that
has suddenly enabled organisms to become
much more correlated over bigger areas
and we have known for a long time that
evolution has taken place in this kind
of step transitions so for example for a
billion years or so no they were just
cyanobacteria and everything was very
boring yeah and then you know suddenly
suddenly things happen you know for
example suddenly 500 million years ago
multicellular life evolved suddenly
organisms were able to do a lot more
than they could because once clusters of
cells were able to interact and were
able to correlate their activity they
were able to do tricks you know for
example they could divide up tasks
between them one end could be for
gathering food and one end could be for
squeezing food all that kind of stuff
and there are a number of such
transitions the evolution of the nervous
system there's another one suddenly an
organism could convey a message from one
side of the cluster of cells to the
other side and so they could coordinate
their activities they could do things
like contract muscles and move and then
when they break
able to move they could move out of one
patch of food and into a new patch of
food and just just open up all sorts of
amazing things and you know there have
been a number of these and with each
step
suddenly organisms have managed to
extend their reach and and become much
more complex and humans I think are a
fantastic example of that and we're now
extending our reach out across space and
out across time and into higher
dimensions and amazing stuff but that
we're doing yeah and I think that so I
think that one of the issues here one of
the one of the features here is that
complexity can build upon itself right I
mean this is certainly the lesson both
of the origin of life and the origin of
multicellularity that there's Oh many
things only so many things that could
happen if there's no life around or if
all the life is unicellular and the
space of possibilities becomes enormous
ly bigger as this phase transition
happens right so physicists think about
these transitions as phase transitions
where this sort of one type of thing
happening and then suddenly a little bit
of something new comes on the scene and
can take over because it's so much more
advantageous and again you know the
biology needs to be a little bit richer
and more nuanced here than the physics
does because so okay fine there can be a
phase transition and you can explore
different parts of the possibility space
but how exactly does that happen and
yeah you know physicists are allowed to
think of things happening in arbitrary
numbers of dimensions or arbitrary
amounts of time but you want to think of
things happening in the real world and
it matters you know chemistry matters as
well as biology right what molecules can
you build and how can they interact with
each other and it's certainly yeah my
think it's it's uncontroversial to say
that the origin of multicellularity
opened up a huge space and in fact 500
million years later we're not anywhere
near done exploring it right things are
still changing very rapidly the
invention of technology has opened up a
whole new set of dimensions of space of
a possibility space of not space space
but do you have a feeling for sort of
what general lesson
we can learn from these transitions or
the existence of them well one of the
things that's quite notable if you look
over the evolution of complex life is
that there have been periods of time
when there's been a sudden decrease in
complexity as well so there have been
several major extinctions where suddenly
things have gone backwards in very large
steps and indeed life has nearly been
obliterated several times so for example
when organisms discovered had a
photosynthesize and suddenly reach out
in space to grab the energy of the Sun
if you like they produced as a byproduct
of activity oxygen and the oxygen levels
in the atmosphere rose very high and
course oxygen is very toxic and there
was a what they call the great
oxygenation could test Rafi it's big
sudden fall and biodiversity there and
there we know other things so for
example when organisms did discover how
to move they discovered her to burrow
through the substrate that they were
living in in the bottom of the ocean and
that allowed mixing of the water in the
ocean with the substrate underneath and
completely changed the chemistry and
again there was a big extinction and a
lot of life-forms disappeared they
didn't all disappear and of course the
ones that were left then gave rise to
what came after and in fact there was a
huge explosion of life after that and
we've had these several extinctions and
life has managed to recover but there is
a feeling when you look at it that it
might not have done that it might have
been the case that the extinction had
been total and I can't see anything in
thermodynamics that rules out that
possibility and of course in situation
that we're in right now where we have
extended our complex reach over space
and time further than any life-forms
ever have before
that also opens up more possibilities
for extinction
than life has ever had before yeah
and I think that there is no
thermodynamic guarantee that we couldn't
extinguish all of life but but let's you
know for the non biologists out there
including myself let's let's dig into
this statement that it was almost
extinguished I mean is that in terms of
a number of species or the number of
organisms I would think that there is
still going to be some unicellular
organisms that would you know tough it
out even in these big events but maybe
I'm wrong well I mean the ones that
happened up to now I have indeed left a
lot of life you know still going both in
terms of number of species and in terms
of numbers of genomes feel like in
different individuals but you know it's
not necessarily the case for example if
we managed to turn the earth into Venus
or you know cover it in radioactivity
then right perhaps we can obliterate all
life so we don't know that life which
when you look at it life seems to be
very dynamic and inherently unstable and
you know rapidly changes into wonderful
complexity but it does feel like it
could also rapidly run into a wall so
something I've been thinking about a lot
is are we about to do that
yeah if we are can we stop it so I think
that thermodynamics gives us no solace
here I do think that this is an
important difference between the very
simple example that we looked at with
cream and coffee where the complexity
just smoothly went up and then smoothly
went down roughly speaking because it
was kind of it was kind of featureless
like there's only two things through the
cream molecules as it were in our
simulation and coffee molecules there
was not a lot of room for different
kinds of things but I think when you're
what you're getting at is that in this
specific case of life there's sort of
mechanisms for this complexity that are
very specific right that there's certain
biological channels for order to be
created if our complexity be to be
created and in some sense they're
fragile right like there's there's sort
of unique ways
or almost unique ways for complexity to
come into existence and build upon
itself and that and I'm not
characterizing that feature as perfectly
as I could but but maybe you know what I
mean and maybe you can do it better but
then this opens up the possibility for
catastrophe right like it's it's good
that it builds this complexity so
effectively but it's bad because it also
opens the possibility for being wiped
out yes yeah I think it's very much a
double-edged sword but given that it
strikes me as interesting that
nevertheless complexity has increased
steadily over the evolution of the
universe and so although in theory it
can be a sawtooth increase nevertheless
it has generally gone up but something
that you said in your talk which made me
kind of pause and contemplate the future
Grimley complexity inevitably as the
universe unfolds over the next 10
billion years is going to go down again
and if I understand you correctly then
the reason is to do with entropy but I'm
not fully sure I have a handle on why so
can you unpack that a bit more sure I
think that you know this is not the kind
of thing that makes us change our life
insurance policies or even you know
change our ecological policies worldwide
but it is true that this idea that
complexity grows is one that can't last
forever at least it's true in the
universe as we know it our universe is
very young in some sense ok it's 14
billion years old which sounds old and
usually when you watch a TV show like
cosmos which explains to you the history
of the universe that treats the Big Bang
is the beginning and today as the end
right like we're at December 31st of
course that's not true the universe is
gonna keep going and you can ask how
does the last fourteen billion years
compared to what comes next we
discovered in 1998 that the universe is
not only expanding but expanding faster
and faster so there's no reason to think
it will ever stop expanding
probably just keep expanding forever but
the part of the universe we can see is
only finite in size because the universe
is accelerating there's a horizon around
us past which you will never be able to
see so there's a finite amount of stuff
in the universe and there's an infinite
amount of time for it to evolve so like
the cream in the coffee it will reach
equilibrium it will reach a point where
everything is smoothed out into its
highest entropy configuration now this
takes a very long time
the oldest stars will burn where the
longest live stars I should say will
burn for trillions of years right we've
only been around for 14 billion years
and stars will still be shining a
trillion years from now but eventually
they will use up all their nuclear fuel
that's a feature of using up entropy
will use up all the hydrogen helium that
we had to burn in the stars and so the
universe will become dark but it still
won't be done yet there will still be a
difference between black holes and
planets and stars but eventually even
that difference will be smoothed out
because all the stars and planets will
fall into black holes so I'll have a
universe with nothing but black holes in
it and eventually even that will go away
because Hawking showed in the 1970s that
black holes evaporate so the black holes
will evaporate into nothingness over a
time scale of about 10 to the 100 years
one Google years in old-fashioned
terminology and then there'll be nothing
but empty space literally forever so
there's no room for complexity in the
heat death of the universe 10 to the 100
years from now maybe there'll be some
tiny ephemeral life forms that form in
the evaporating black hole atmospheres I
don't know that seems very unlikely to
me and very unsatisfying it's certainly
very different than what we have right
now but yeah in some very real sense we
are in the part of the history of the
universe and in the few billion years of
the history of the universe where stars
are forming and shining and enacting is
really robust entropy low entropy energy
sources that allow life to exist but
that is in some sense a very temporary
condition so that's I mean that's a very
grim prospect it's quite depressed
I don't know why I'm gonna be long gone
my cell years of years trillions of
years yes still the idea that it can it
cannot last forever but again it seems
to be very woven up with space because
if you think that the driver for
complexity is the ability of systems to
reach out in space and and kind of grab
entropy if you like from around them
themselves it seems like space is
expanding faster than they can do that
and eventually will expand beyond the
realms of the possibility so for example
even if we managed to become a super
civilization that could harvest energy
from you know all around us and manage
to stop ourselves from going extinct and
all the rest of it eventually the
universe would just get so big that we
couldn't find any of the energy anyway
it's too far away and too little of it
is it ya know that's completely true I
mean the way the way you can you can say
it I'm not sure that space is crucial in
this particular case what's crucial is
entropy again in the sense that we have
not reached the maximum of entropy that
we can reach so as long as we're not at
our maximum entropy state there's still
room for something interesting to happen
right for some complex structure to be
there and persist and think and love and
care and die and write poetry but as you
get closer and closer to maximum entropy
there's less and less room for anything
complex and interesting to happen so
that's the ultimate fuel crisis of the
world right like energy is conserved but
entropy is not entropy goes up and so
the difference between where we are and
thermal equilibrium just decreases with
time and so you're right eventually
there'll be no more room left we'll have
used up all of our what we call free
energy that's the technical term the
free energy will go to zero
yeah and life will be over and not only
will they be no more living creatures
there'll be no memory of you having ever
existed sorry is there no way we can
stop this like good advice
technological civilizations somehow stop
this in theory so I think the answer is
no and even in theory you can't you
could imagine building something a
record right like so I don't think it's
actually possible but but it's within
the realm of conceivability that you
could make it an artifact that recorded
your greatest deeds right and and and
lasted for an arbitrarily long period of
time but what would be impossible for
anyone to read that artifact because the
act of reading and remembering increases
the entropy of the universe and if
you're at maximum entropy that can't
happen so consciousness itself you know
thought and life cannot exist once
you've reached equilibrium but that's
assuming that the second law is
completely unchangeable but is that is
that okay yeah never mind the clock back
my money's on the second law you know
there is something called the recurrence
theorem that if you wait long enough if
you live in the universe where there's
only a finite number of things that can
happen
truly finite number of things that can
happen not just that we can observe then
you will fluctuate back into a low
entropy state but that that causes all
sorts of problems with things like
Boltzmann brains and things like that
and it doesn't it seemed to very clearly
not be the universe we actually live in
so I don't think that that you know not
only is it not the universe we live in
but it wouldn't really ameliorate your
problem because you couldn't send
messages from one part of time to
another through the point of equilibrium
so not a lot of room for talking to your
future friends could be find a way to
borrow from here into an adjacent
universe that's still in a very low
entropy State and borrow some of their
entropy not according to any laws of
physics that we know about them I mean
this is good to think about you know if
you want to this is very long-term
planning you know the long now would be
embarrassed about how the short term
they're thinking compress yeah no I know
but it's a as far as I know no I mean so
what is poss-eye
is that a new universe will be born from
ours right that a baby universe will be
born again no information will be
conveyed from us to them but it's
possible that at what we think of as the
universe is just part of a bigger
multiverse and more universes are
constantly created and the way that
those universes are created naturally
starts them in a low entropy state from
which they can grow and things can
happen and in fact it's very possible in
fact I proposed a theory which this is
true that our universe came from a
pre-existing universe in exactly that
way but again they can't talk to each
other as far as anyone knows that's the
downside yeah if you haven't had enough
of listening to my voice or of hearing
me talk about quantum mechanics
audible.com is the place to go to get
even more my new book something deeply
hidden is now out I spent four days of
my life
recording the audio book for something
deeply hidden so maybe it will be a good
way for you to catch up on your quantum
mechanics can download it from audible
today and it's not just my book they
have other books as well audible is a
wonderful way to get books as well as
updates from the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal and so forth delivered
right to your favorite audio device as a
member of audible every month you can
choose one audio book regardless of
price as well as two audible originals
and also unlimited access to exclusive
guided fitness and meditation programs
start listening with a thirty-day
audible trial with one audiobook and two
originals absolutely free by visiting
audible.com slash mindscape or texting
mindscape to 500 500 that's audible.com
slash mindscape or texting the word
mindscape to five zero zero five zero
zero start listening today so can I ask
you another question and something I've
been trying to understand so a lot of
these processes that we've talked about
for example the cream and the coffee or
the converse with sushi seems to be a
creation of order which has oils
separating from water these
Changez and complexity linked with
entropy seem to depend on gravity and
effect everything seems to depend on
gravity so the formation of of stars and
planets and life and like it's it's all
depended on gravity to what extent does
gravity a fundamental part of this or as
is it not well I think that it's part of
a fundamental part I mean let me very
briefly mention that oil and water
separating actually increases entropy as
that happens which it must because
entropy increases but it's that's
because of detailed chemistry properties
of you know hydrophilic and hydrophobic
molecules in the oil that it's actually
a higher entropy configuration for them
to be not mixed then for them to be
mixed but it's neat gravity for the oil
to be on surface well even if you didn't
have gravity the oil and water would
still separate yeah they're mean they're
being globules right so gravity does
have that effect of sort of segregating
or stratifying or whatever it is things
in certain ways but it's only because
there's also other forces right so I
think that what is important is not
gravity per se but the fact that there
are different forces that work in
different directions so there can be a
competition between them right that's
when things can become interesting when
you're looking for an equilibrium
between some push and pull of gravity
trying to push things together and let's
say electromagnetism pushing them apart
that's the fact that we have these two
forces that both act over long ranges in
the universe gravity electromagnetism
seems to be a minimal requirement for
really interesting complex structures to
form okay so again that's that being
able to reach out in space and time as a
prerequisite for complexity and I guess
you could think of the role of gravity
as being to bring things together to
move things through space so they can
interact in ways that they couldn't have
otherwise yes absolutely but you know
gravity is subtle also like this is I
mean even even at the physics level
which I keep saying correctly is way
more simple-minded than the biological
level
on the one hand gravity pulls things
together on the other hand it's also the
expansion of the universe it counts as
gravity right that's part of the
geometry of space-time which Einstein
told us is is what we think of as
gravity so the fact that the universe is
accelerating and eventually pushing
things apart is also gravity so it's the
thing we don't understand cosmologically
is why the universe started in such a
low entropy state with 10 to the 88th
particles stuck into a region the size
of a cubic centimeter which seems absurd
and then everything expanded and cooled
from there to be billions of light years
across but it's all gravity that does
both those things so gravity is is your
friend for a little while but then it's
ultimately your enemy if you want to be
a complex structure ok I didn't know
that gravity is driving the expansion of
the universe can you can you explain
that too yeah I mean there's two senses
in which that's true one is just a very
very blunt sense in which the size of
the universe changing over time one way
or the other is a gravitational
phenomenon Einstein back in 1915
explained that what gravity is is the
Kircher of space-time and in a universe
that is more or less uniform through
space one of the features of what we
call the curvature of space-time is the
changing size of the spatial universe
the scale factor as we call it in
general relativity that tells us the
relative distance between distant
galaxies right so the fact that galaxies
are moving apart from each other they're
not moving through space space is
growing and that is a phenomenon due
ultimately to general relativity which
is the theory of gravity there you go
okay but then there's the extra new
feature that at least in the old days
even though the expansion of the
universe was part of our gravitational
theory general relativity at least
gravity was attractive right at least it
was slowing down but in 1998 when we
discovered the acceleration of the
universe we realized that there is
probably something that we call the
vacuum energy to cause Marshall constant
which is pushing things away it's still
gravity right it's still it's not a new
force sometimes people say we discovered
a new force of nature but that's not
right it's the old force gravity the
first force we ever discovered but
there's a new kind of stuff the vacuum
energy whose gravitational effect is to
push things apart so there you go even
gravity can have tricks up its sleeve so
I'd like this to entropy then so I still
kind of think of entropy as somewhat
bound up with space so for example it's
the gas molecules that are in half the
box versus the whole box and the
probability of finding one of those
molecules in a particular place and so
on and so on so if you suddenly doubled
the size of the box and all the
particles were on the one side then as
it would be unfolded they would spread
out across the the box and naively it
feels to me that the more space you've
got the more microscopic configurations
are possible so does that mean I would
agree with that
yeah expansion of space is somehow tied
up with how much entropy is as possible
yeah well it's slightly tricky as I want
to say yes but I want to then put a
footnote the thing that is a little bit
hard to to internalize is that the
expansion of space is part of the
physical system so when you say how much
entropy is possible you really shouldn't
fix space at a certain size this is you
know just a feature general relativity
you can always make space Baker that's
one of the things that can happen
so unlike good old classical system
mechanics when you talk about putting
gas in a box and fixing the boundaries
of the box if your box is the universe
you have to allow the box to expand
that's just part of the dynamics so when
you when we say that in the early
universe there was a cubic centimeter
where all the particles that we now see
in the universe were somehow confined in
a relatively smooth distribution it's
not quite legit to say let's calculate
all the ways we could arrange those
the a da the particles inside a cubic
centimeter and compare them to how many
ways we could arrange the particles
today and say that the possible entropy
has gone up because among the weird
things about that initial condition is
that it was small right that it was
within the cubic centimeter so you can't
separate out the arrangements of the
particles inside the box from the size
of the box itself so the lesson is still
true that yes the entropy was very low
back then it is much larger now but it's
not that the allowed entropy went up
it's just that we weren't ever coming
close to accessing the allowed entropy
of that early time so what determines
the allowed entropy then if what if that
doesn't change if you can't and you seem
to be saying that it's not meaningful to
say that so talk about the number of
ways that you could arrange all of those
particles in that centimeter well you
you can talk about that but you can't
say that's the maximum entropy right
because you could say well but I can
make the Box bigger and there's even
bigger entropy right right okay so see
the problem so I'm thinking I have to
reference friends in my head at the same
time one is the centimeter squared
universe with all the particles jammed
in and unable to move so right therefore
lower entropy because you can't
rearrange them where can they go yeah
and then the other one is the large
universe where that could be all over
the place and that feels like there's a
lot more ways that you could do that and
that's a very high entropy yeah but it
doesn't look wrecked
you can't have those two reference
frames at the same time well you can't
what what you can't say sorry there's
yet another subtlety here here here's
the yet other subtlety
when matter is extremely densely packed
as it was in the early universe
gravity not just over the expansion of
the universe scales but gravity the
gravitational pull of the particles on
each other was really important right I
mean it's very densely packed that that
makes perfect sense when when matter is
very densely packed
high entropy doesn't mean smooth anymore
right in a box of gas a high entropy
configuration is a smooth uniform
configuration but when gravity when the
mutual gravity between the particles
becomes important you increase entropy
by making things lumpier like in the
current universe you could make a black
hole the black hole the center of our
galaxy has more entropy than all the
particles in the known universe right so
the fact that the entropy was very with
the configuration was very smooth at
early times is itself a low entropy fact
right it's it's not only that everything
was packed into a tiny region of space
which is true and low entropy but also
it was smooth which is low entropy so
cosmologists some of my best friends you
know professional cosmologists have this
idea which is a hundred percent false
that the early universe had high entropy
because they say you know look it was it
was smooth and it was hot and it was
glowing like a blackbody looks like it
was thermal equilibrium looks like a box
of gas and that's entirely wrong because
both you know it was a very small box of
gas and because it was smooth even
though gravity was important so it was a
anomalously low entropy state from
anyway you slice it so then it's been
increasing ever since and we're gonna
keep increasing and it's fascinating and
it's it's full employment for I think
physicists and biologists to study the
specifics of the ways in which is
increasing so cosmologists will talk
about forming black holes and then
evaporating and biologists will talk
about all of these complex structures
acting as entropy engines right I mean
that's what life does in some sense yeah
yeah I mean life you know I was
introduced to Schrodinger's idea of life
as being a sort of temporary reversal of
entropy I came across that that concept
a long time ago and that's always it's
always struck me as I mean obviously
right and I think he didn't accept it
either but at the same time and it did
always plant this idea well you know why
does life do that why is it the universe
not just not just drift out and diffuse
and
and not only has it formed but it
continues to do more and more and more
and more crazy and interesting things I
just think that's amazing well I think
you know here's one way of that I think
about it but this is very primitive and
we should be able to do better the space
of possibilities is really large right
when you have a lot of particles and
there's a lot of places they could be in
the universe and there's a lot of ways
they could interact with each other and
so forth there's a lot of things that
can happen and the journey from the
early universe where entropy was low to
the very very late universe where we're
in equilibrium is one of exploring that
space right because in equilibrium by
definition is sort of an equal
probability to be in any configuration
but just because the set of
configurations is so big you're not
actually even in the 10 to the 100 years
that it takes the universe to
equilibrate you're not gonna come close
to actually exploring every single
arrangement of stuff within that
universe so it's easy to say sure you
explore more and more of the allowed
phase space or whatever it is but the
way in which that happens specifically
is the crucial question when it comes to
life and complexity and things like that
and they're like I think you keep
correctly emphasizing space matters
because life is you know and organized
by itself low entropy thing that can
exist only because it's increasing
entropy elsewhere in space in some sense
yeah yeah I mean the reason that life
can do that is because of the spatial
properties of the carbon atom so you
know it because of its three-dimensional
symmetrical structure it's able to build
these amazing molecules that can reach
out and make these you know as you noted
these interactions across space and time
so without carbon we wouldn't have one
of us and I find myself often wondering
whether this has ever happened anywhere
else
I used to assume that it must have in
many places in the universe yeah but as
time has gone on I started to think
actually maybe maybe it's never happened
anywhere else maybe this is really
unique the particular
conditions that have allowed
carbon-based life to form and remain
stable
maybe that's so unusual as to be unique
well I think I've had that thought also
and I'm my attitude is that we don't
have any data here right we don't have a
lot of data about the fraction of other
planets or other environments that have
life on them so we should be very
open-minded maybe within our observable
universe the earth is the only planet
that ever had life form on it
there's certainly another option right
which is that since life seem to catch
on pretty quickly on earth but
multicellular life took a very long time
to form or eukaryotic life or something
like that took a long time to form maybe
those are the hard parts and when we
visit other planets they'll be you know
some sort of cyanobacteria all over the
place but nothing more interesting yeah
well they probably feel interesting
maybe maybe but I do but you bring up
this question of the necessity of carbon
so I wondered about that too I mean
obviously carbon is crucial for life as
we know it but are we just so
chauvinistic about that if the chemistry
of carbon were completely different I'm
open to the possibility that life could
have formed in some very bizarre to us
but very different way yeah I don't know
enough biochemistry no I think there are
one or two other atoms that might have
the structure you know the the ability
to form the the tetrahedral bonds and so
on but it's you know these long stable
polymers that that carbon can form that
enables us to grow these incredibly
complex little machines that constitute
we enzymes if we were very advanced if
we were max tegmark we would wonder
about you know could life exist if space
we're one-dimensional versus
two-dimensional versus three-dimensional
versus four-dimensional and which is
fine to do which is fun but the answer
always is that it can only happen when
it's three-dimensional and I just really
worried that we were being blinded by
our the noses in front of our faces when
it comes to that like we know how it
works in this case we can't see how it
would
in other cases but I'm a little bit more
skeptical that it couldn't just because
we don't know how it would yeah I mean
one thing we do know is we don't see any
signs of it when we look into the cosmos
so there is other life it's not gone
sufficiently advanced to be able to make
signals that we can detect you wouldn't
know we the currents correct me if I'm
wrong with the current state of the art
is we wouldn't know if all the
exoplanets we've ever seen are covered
in cyanobacteria right I'm not sure why
would we not know that just the current
state of the art doesn't give us a lot
of information spectroscopic information
I think that's it yeah I think that
there you know the planets are faint
compared to their stars but before we
but before we get too crazy in our in
our speculations I do want to bring
things a little bit down to earth again
because it's easy for me to say that
complexity comes and then goes and I
think you very correctly want to
emphasize the non smoothness of that
evolution over time in the real world
can you say a little bit more about the
origin of these catastrophes you know I
mean I know there's specific
catastrophes that we know about are
there general features of catastrophes
that decrease the complexity of a system
at least biologically if not more
generally well I think the catastrophes
that have occurred for life on Earth in
fact there have been quite a few you
know paleo biologists have identified
five major extinctions but actually I
mean extinctions are happening all the
time and sometimes extinction rate
increases and decreases but there have
been a few really big ones some of these
have been contributed by changes in the
earth itself so massive volcanic
activity and so on but the ones that
interest me are the ones that were due
to life something that happened an
evolution that suddenly changed the the
distribution of life so I think probably
the first really notable one was the
great oxygenation event that really
completely changed change the chemistry
of Earth and then there was the Cambrian
substrate revolution that I mentioned
when when life-forms discovered how to
move and then how to burrow through the
substrate and so on another big one that
was quite surprising to me is that when
life came out of the oceans and onto
land and trees formed suddenly there was
a massive increase in photosynthesis and
poling of carbon dioxide out of the air
and that plummeted the temperature of
the earth and created an ice age and
then of course there's the one that
we're doing now we've completely
changing the chemistry of the planet and
we're seeing a massive extinction and
again that's because we've we've managed
to proliferate enough to have you know
global effects on the on the planets
chemistry so those are find those quite
interesting the worrying but interesting
life exploring the parameter space and
then every now and then it finds itself
in a dead end
yeah I think that the lesson of all your
examples is that these catastrophes were
all driven by progress right like life
discovered a new way to do something
exciting and fun and did it a little bit
too enthusiastically right and then led
to the extinction of a whole bunch of
other life forms yeah yeah so you know
you can when you when you develop a new
ability to extend your reach in space
and time some that'll lead gen all sorts
of paths and some of those paths will
lead you to bigger and greater things
but other other paths will lead you to
it has to be you know evolution is full
of dead ends and we can't tell in
advance which are going to be the dead
ends and which are not but we were
particularly interesting because we as
far as we know the first species that
have that have been able to know this
and to contemplate our future and the
possible regions of the space that we
can explore and to make choices
theoretically but the question is does
the dynamics of our interactions among
ourselves
allow those choices to be made or are we
condemned to you know just just follow
this path that's going to lead us off a
cliff and I don't know the answer yeah I
mean I think one way of thinking about
the evolution of life is not only an
evolution of complexity in terms of the
structures that make the physical
organism but an evolution of the
sophistication with which we deal with
information right the first RNA or DNA
molecules actually carried some
information and that was crucial
obviously and then there was this sort
of differentiation of information when
you got to eukaryotic life and there's
mitochondrial DNA and nuclear DNA and so
forth and then multicellular life
there's a you know and more
differentiation and then when the brain
came along in the nervous system you
could think and you could have
self-awareness and now that we have
language you can think symbolically and
these are all you know information
processing leaps forward so that I think
is another wonderful frontier in science
is to think about insights from
information theory and how they relate
to physical evolution both of the
universe under the biology within it
yeah yeah one of the things that
fascinates me about that is there's the
equivalents that's been made between
entropy and information mm-hmm in some
sense disease information processing
engines if you like brains are
performing their own kind of you know
entropic manipulations by virtue of how
they operate in different domains you
know the chemical level but also it was
kind of more abstract level which i
think is fascinating ya know I think
it's absolutely like I said it's it's
gonna be full employment for future
scientists because in some sense the way
I like to think of it is well let me let
me back up a little bit because people
get confused we talk about entropy and
information because information
theorists define the relationship
between entropy in information in
exactly the opposite way to how
physicists define it because the it
information theory grew out of Claude
Shannon talking about you know how to
sense
signals over wires and you send
information more efficiently through a
code that is high entropy because high
entropy means you don't know what
letters coming next every time you get a
letter you get some new information it's
very useful right so they so information
theorists or communication theorists
like to link high entropy with high
information content whereas a physicist
who thinks about the cup of coffee not a
message over the wires says if I'm in a
low entropy state if you tell me eh
you're in a low entropy state then I
know a lot about what state you're in
because there's only a few of those
states that look like that so I have
more information about the system when
it's in a low entropy configuration and
I think that for this discussion that
we're having right now it's that
definition of entropy that is more
germane I think that in some sense
because the universe started in a very
low entropy state it started with a lot
of information in some sense built in
and all we've been doing we haven't been
increasing the information content of
the universe by having life or thoughts
or books we've been degrading it because
entropy is increasing but we've been
using manipulating taking advantage of
the fact that entropy that information
is all around us in more and more
interesting ways so breaking the
universe up into these subsystems that
manipulate information is a wonderfully
proof away I think of thinking about
life and species in evolution right so
interesting is another way of saying
complex I guess so you can say that the
universe started off with a lot of
information but not much interest
informative but more interesting yes and
I think you know this is something that
you you get at with vo your questions
about space and interactions and things
like that because the universe as a
whole
increases in entropy and decreases in
information but it gets shuffled around
in interesting ways and certain parts of
the universe like you and me can
hopefully take advantage of the overall
degradation of information around us to
make life interesting as we go
I feel like we're living at an optimum
time and the evolution of complexity in
the universe where it is maximally
interesting well you know they might
have said that 10,000 years ago too
because they didn't know right the top
of the hill or is it can we still climb
it a bit higher well I think that you
know what what what you would you have
correctly pointed out is that there's no
inevitability in this increase in
complexity like sure maybe there's a
trend maybe there's a tendency but
there's also this very definite
empirical record of catastrophes right
and so when you see us dumping carbon
into the atmosphere and the sea levels
rising and stuff like that don't be
sanguine that oh yeah with life is
resilient and everything will be okay we
could hurt it really badly yeah that's
that's a very good take-home message are
you are you optimistic overall about how
we're gonna do not optimistic but
hopeful I think there is there are
things we could do but if you gave if
you asked me to put a probability on it
I'd probably have to say it was Louis
Louis yeah
well I hope not but you know all we can
do is is the estimated probability is
less important than trying to increase
them I think that's the thing to do if
any species can can do it then it's us
there you go let's put it that way I
like that yeah the cats are not gonna
save us believe me I have two cats and
they are not going to stop global
climate change in any way Kate Jeffery
thanks so much for be on the podcast is
a tremendously fun conversation thank
you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]